another beautiful day to bust some myths
hmm interesting
what am i having for lunch wait a minute
[Music]
i'm sorry but the old michelle can't
come to the phone right now
why oh cause she's dead
hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd skin care nerd and
propaganda source today i'm going to be
talking about a recent study
it's on the sunscreen ingredient
octocrylane turning into benzophenone
according to the paper benzophenone
causes mutations
cancer and endocrine disruptions i
wasn't going to do a whole thing on this
paper because it only really got a lot
of attention in france and nowhere else
but then i saw that i was cited in it
twice
like and subscribe if you're into
sunscreen propaganda and click the
notification bell if you want
hot piping skincare propaganda so
this paper benzophenone accumulates over
time from the degradation of octocrylene
in commercial sunscreen products
it's a bit weird it's open access and
i've linked it in the description if you
want to give it a read
let's start by looking at what the
research researchers actually did in a
science paper this is in the methods and
results sections
and this part is pretty standard
octocrylene is a pretty common sunscreen
ingredient
and under certain conditions it can turn
into another chemical called
benzophenone
which the paper paints out to be really
really nasty
more on that later the researchers
bought 17 different sunscreens
3 bottles of each and 16 of these had
octocrylene
they measured the amount of benzophenone
in them right after buying them and then
they kept them for six weeks at 40
degrees celsius
in stability testing this approximates
one year of normal storage
then they tested the benzophenone levels
again they found that at the start
there was benzophenone in all of the
octa cryolean sunscreens
an average of 39 parts per million there
was barely any in the one without
octocrylene
after the six-week storage they found
that the benzophenone went up in all of
the octocrylline sunscreens by between
15 and almost 200 percent the average
was 75 parts per million of benzophenone
and the sunscreen with the highest
concentration had 435 parts per million
there are some limitations with this
study the most obvious one is that six
weeks at 40 degrees celsius
isn't quite the same as one year of
normal storage there'll be some
reactions that go
at 40 degrees celsius that wouldn't
normally go at room temperature
but based on this study it's probably
safe to say that some octocrylene and
sunscreens will turn into benzophenone
over time
is this actually a problem well this is
the controversial part of this paper
the interpretation of what this means
how the paper tries to put the results
into context
this is in the introduction and
discussion parts of the paper
if you just read the paper then it seems
like the science is pretty clear
benzophenone is really dangerous snake
emoji snake emoji snake emoji
the start of the abstract benzophenone
is a mutagen carcinogen and endocrine
disruptor in the intro there's
four chunky paragraphs on how bad
benzophenone is
benzophenone is associated with a wide
range of toxicities including
genotoxicity
carcinogenicity and endocrine disruption
benzophenone is an established
carcinogen the problem is
the evidence that the author's site to
show that benzophenone is so incredibly
scary
it's mostly in vitro assays studies in
cells
in mice and guinea pigs and rats and
zebrafish things were not
this isn't the scientific consensus in
humans at all
the authors cite a few reviews on the
risks of benzophenone in humans in this
paper
these reviews looked at the same
evidence the in vitro and animal studies
that the authors looked
at and they came to very different
conclusions the international agency on
researching cancer
their report concludes that there's no
data in humans there's no solid
explanation for how
benzophenone could cause cancer in
humans but
because it happened in animals they
can't say whether or not it would also
happen in humans
so they basically went and put
benzophenone in group 2b
possibly carcinogenic to humans this
sounds pretty bad
but it means that it missed out on group
1 carcinogenic to humans
and group 2a probably carcinogenic to
humans
other things in group 2b include lead
progestogen-only contraceptives
mobile phone radiation and aloe vera
extract
it's a mixed bag so not exactly as
strong as stance as you'd think from
reading the statements in this paper
they also cite the european food safety
authority who did a safety assessment in
2017.
as you probably guessed they were
looking at eating benzophenone which is
considered worse than just putting it on
your skin
their conclusions there is no concern
with respect to genotoxicity
the panel concludes that there is no
safety concern for benzophenone under
the current condition of use
as a flavoring substance which again
doesn't really match what the authors of
this study are saying
but it does explain the fact that
benzophenone isn't on that eu list of
banned ingredients and cosmetics that
clean beauty people like to point to
and it also explains the fact that
safety assessors already know that
there's benzophenone in sunscreens and
they're okay with it
benzophenone is a known contaminant in
the octocryllin that gets put into
sunscreens
it's actually listed on the safety data
sheets from the suppliers
that means that toxicologists do
actually consider the benzophenone that
you rub onto your skin when they're
doing safety assessments for octocylene
sunscreens
octocrylene is used at 10 max in
sunscreens
the highest amount measured in the study
is a fair bit higher than 10 percent of
the known benzophenon contamination
from popular ultracryline suppliers but
the french federation of beauty
enterprises points out that
even with the highest benzophenone
sunscreen from this study
if you apply 18 grams of sunscreen a day
you still end up with less than half a
milligram of benzophenone this is three
times less than the maximum allowed dose
if you're eating it so how do the
authors explain why their conclusions
are so different from the scientific
consensus
well they kind of just say that the
other people are wrong the risks have
been underestimated in both toxicology
journal papers and organizational
reports
this is unfortunate not only that but
the authors say that these other people
can be argued to be unjustified and
irresponsibly reckless
so all of these scientists who
specialize in human toxicology
you can check out their cvs and
conflicts of interest on the efsa
website
the eu doesn't mess around when it comes
to regulation they're all wrong
but the authors are right
let's look at the authors there are five
authors four of them are from an
ocean research institution one of them
is a human toxicologist but he's retired
and he's not affiliated with any
research institutions
but their actual qualifications don't
always matter maybe they have good
evidence
maybe they reference other authoritative
sources that are as qualified and
reputable as the iarc
and the efsa and maybe they say that the
body of evidence shows that benzophenone
is really dangerous to humans
no none of the references say this the
evidence that the authors cite
apart from all the in vitro and animal
studies that experts with much more
expertise have interpreted completely
differently
ah a court case lawyers aren't exactly
qualified in toxicology so that doesn't
mean much
and supposedly proposition 65 they say
under the state of california
proposition 65 there is no safe harbor
or allowable level of benzophenone
contamination in a product
and they say that this reflects the
dangers of benzophenone so this makes it
sound like california thinks that
benzophenone is so bad
that no level should be allowed that's
not how it works
prop 65 is a law that makes companies
put up warning signs about potential
toxic chemicals
you might know it from the coffee and
potato chips and disneyland give you
cancer science that went viral a while
back
firstly this regulation obviously
results in a lot of warning signs that
don't really mean much in reality
this is because it takes a hazard based
approach which is what i talked about in
my clean beauty video
clean beauty does the same thing if
something has a potentially dangerous
substance in it
then it gets a prop 65 warning it
doesn't matter what dose you get and how
you get it whether you inhale it or eat
it or put it on your skin
these different exposures are pretty
darn fundamental when it comes to
toxicology
obviously injecting a liter of something
versus putting half a drop on your skin
are going to have very different effects
but that aside more importantly
no safe harbor in proposition 65 doesn't
mean that something is so bad that no
level is allowed
it actually means that they just haven't
decided on a safe level yet
there are lots of chemicals that don't
have a level and they're slowly being
added to proposition 65
and this makes more sense because if
benzophenone was so bad it's never
allowed
then graves would be illegal in
california grapes naturally have
benzophenone in them
the paper also says that 70 of
benzophenone that you put on your skin
gets absorbed but if you look at the
study that they refer to
it's 70 absorption under occlusion in
other words 70
absorbs if you apply it and then wrap it
up in cling wrap
which is not how we wear sunscreen the
paper does an uncovered absorption as
well and this is a much less scary
sounding 44
it's in the same table it's right next
to 70 so for some reason the authors
quoted the less relevant measurement
also it was done in monkeys so to me
there seems to be a sort of pattern
in how the authors are selecting and
presenting the evidence about
benzophenone
now the authors don't just disagree with
the scientific consensus about
benzophenone toxicology
they also disagree with dermatologists
about sunscreen the authors implied that
dermatologists and marketing propaganda
shouldn't be taken seriously when they
recommend wearing sunscreen regularly
throughout the year
and reapplying sunscreen i don't think i
have to point this out but
this is the medical consensus from all
of these
organizations and then joining the ranks
of people that the authors disagree with
because
haters gonna hate hate hate hate hate
there's me
apparently i'm part of various
propaganda sources
and while i'm really flattered to be
cited not just once but twice
it's also really bizarre although maybe
not that bizarre in the context of this
paper
i'm a youtuber i'm not a huge media
outlet
and i'm not an academic i mean this is
me
[Music]
and the two blog posts that got cited
were actually some of the least
propagandary of my posts
they were the ones where i talked about
the studies that the fda did that the
media reported as
sunscreen chemicals soak all the way
into your bloodstream sunscreens seep
into your blood
i pointed out that we don't have to
freak out about sunscreens and change
sunscreens
my sneaky propaganda tactics were
quoting actual lines from the study
quoting the fda who did the study
quoting the editors of the journal that
published the study
quoting experts quoting the american
academy of dermatology
i guess maybe the authors think that
we're all propaganda and we should be
listening to the media headlines instead
maybe this is impostor syndrome talking
but i don't really feel like i'm doing
that well at this whole propaganda thing
so why did a bunch of scientists come
out with a paper that makes so many
unusual claims i mean i've read a lot of
peer-reviewed papers
but disputing the scientific consensus
of cancer organizations and
toxicologists
and dermatologists without much evidence
and citing a beauty blogger
it's really just a lot in the one paper
well i think looking at what else the
authors have done gives a bit of insight
here
like i said four of them are from an
ocean research institute
and one of them used to be a human
toxicologist i think the obvious
question is
why didn't they collaborate with an
academic who currently works in human
toxicology the only author who
specializes in human toxicology on this
paper that talks a lot about human
toxicology
is someone who firstly isn't affiliated
with an academic institution
but also he's retired and he doesn't
have a phd
it's weird i know this sounds elitist
but that's just how scientific academia
works
your first step in your training is
getting a phd and it's not a one-off
either
it's a bit of a pattern in the
publication history of the first two
authors
craig downes and joseph donato craig
downs is the scientist who published and
promoted the choral studies that led to
the whole reefsafe sunscreen thing in
2018. he's been very active in getting
particular chemical sunscreens banned in
places like hawaii
since then he's published more studies
on how sunscreen impacts aquatic
organisms
which is what you'd expect from a marine
biologist but he's also started
collaborating with joseph donato author
2
on papers about human toxicology the
only link between these papers
and his older work is that they're all
about how bad chemical sunscreen is
in all sorts of different ways which is
weird scientists usually have expertise
in a specific field
and they specialize in particular
methodologies they don't jump around
different fields focusing on a specific
group of chemicals
this publication history doesn't make a
lot of sense in my opinion
but if you look at some of the other
things that downs and dinardo have said
outside of their peer review
publications then
you can sort of see that all roads seem
to lead back to chemical sunscreens
increasing melanoma rates it's because
of too much sunscreen even though
dermatologists and the american academy
of dermatology
and the skin cancer foundation all say
that sunscreen can reduce skin cancer
they say that the increasing melanoma
rates are because of better detection
and different lifestyle habits
apparently they're wrong declining coral
reefs um it's my professional opinion
that most of the coral reefs in the last
40 years have died because your bathroom
than anything else climate change oil
spills what have you
i think this goes without saying but
this is very much not what most coral
scientists think
the consensus is that the biggest
threats to coral are climate change
ecosystem changes from things like
overfishing and land-based pollution
from things like agriculture
there's a recent open access review that
looks at all the studies on sunscreen
and coral
the measurements that downs took around
hawaii were ten to a thousand times
higher than any other published
measurements
the conclusion is organic uv filters do
occur in the environment
but according to our analysis there is
limited evidence to suggest
that their presence is causing
significant harm to coral reefs
although more research should be done as
you might have expected
donato has said that their lead author
was hired by big sunscreen
now i think there are definitely lots of
legitimate criticisms of the beauty and
personal care industry
and we can't just trust everything they
say i mean i talk about marketing myths
all the time but that doesn't mean that
the complete opposite of what the
industry says
is always going to be true and what are
the chances that everyone in the
industry and in toxicology dermatology
and coral science are all in on the same
conspiracy to protect big sunscreen
people like to blab in a decades-old
conspiracy there's going to be thousands
of people involved
how has no one leaked receipts about all
their secret meetings and how people are
getting paid off
i think if you have to dispute the
scientific consensus
in multiple fields to support your
theory including fields that you don't
have expertise in
and you don't have strong evidence that
other people haven't seen before
to support your theory then maybe it's
time to ask yourself if
maybe you're being a bit biased what
about the other three authors
i mentioned this before but one of the
weird things about this paper is where
it took off
it's a paper in english and the authors
are from the us and france
in france the paper took off almost
immediately after it was published it
was all over the media but in the u.s
there was barely a blip
this discrepancy is really weird
skincare people talk about sunscreen all
the time but for everyone else and the
media in general
interest in sunscreen is cyclical there
are exceptions but it's pretty rare for
people to care this much about a small
study
in a country where people mostly just
wear sunscreen to the beach if at all
so what's going on here's one suggestion
i've seen from french bloggers and
beauty experts
if you look at the conflicts of interest
section of the paper that ocean research
institute that four of the authors work
at
has partnerships with pierre fabrera a
huge french cosmetic and pharmaceutical
company
a few days after this paper was
published pierre farber announced that
they were launching a sunscreen with a
new filter called tri-sorb
and octocryllin-free features heavily in
their marketing the timing and the hype
that was almost entirely isolated to one
country
does seem a bit suspicious but pierre
farber have denied any involvement
i don't think that a conflict of
interest means that the science will
automatically be compromised
it's unfortunate that science is
expensive and a lot of topics just
aren't that high up on the priority list
for the government to fund them without
commercial interest
but it's a bit of a strange
juxtaposition with all this stuff in the
paper about marketing propaganda and big
sunscreen
another study came out from a belgium
research group at the end of march
and they found that benzophenone
increased after octocrylline sunscreens
were kept at high temperatures
so again i don't think the experiment
part of this study was wrong but if you
compare the two papers you can see how
differently the two papers contextualize
their findings
the other paper mentions that
benzophenone is a potential endocrine
disruptor and carcinogen
but it really highlights the potential
part there are a bunch of other things i
haven't mentioned that to me
also seem like pretty big red flags for
example donato's public email address
for a while was chemicals are toxic
gmail.com dancers lab runs a program
that's a lot like the ewg approved label
where they'll certify that your
sunscreens are reef safe
for a fee last minute edit last week one
of the authors from the lab
affiliated with pierre fabra commented
on my coral reef posts about adding info
on octocrylean being bad
i'm not sure why he's reaching out to
someone he called a propaganda source
seems kinda sus so what are the
takeaways from this
with octocrylene and benzophenone the
vast majority of scientists don't think
that benzophenone is as bad as the paper
makes it out to be
but the amount can get higher than
expected although it is still within the
margin of safety for oral exposure
so hopefully there'll be a bit more
research on how benzophenone affects
humans when we put it on our skin
and sunscreen formulators will focus on
ways of stabilizing octocrylene
in the meantime as many skincare experts
have said
it's probably still safe to use
octocrylene sunscreens as long as you're
not allergic to them but it's safest to
not use sunscreens after they're used by
date
and not expose them to high temperatures
which you were hopefully doing anyway
the wider takeaway is that you can't
trust everything you read just because
it's in a peer-reviewed paper
this paper had five authors who all
apparently signed off on this
and there were four anonymous reviewers
as well stuff slips through peer review
all the time
especially when it's commentary around
the relevance of the research
that part isn't checked anywhere near as
thoroughly as the actual experimental
part of the paper
now for some propaganda from big
learning if you like poisoning your
brain with education you're going to
love this
the first thousand to click the link in
the description will get a free trial of
skillshare's premium membership
skillshare is an online community with a
massive range of classes on all sorts of
propagandary topics like photography
design video editing time management
classes are mostly less than an hour so
you can quickly level up and get those
propaganda bugs
i usually use skillshare to help me make
better content for big sunscreen
but recently i've been watching a lot of
classes about cooking there's a lot of
big delicious propaganda on there from
real life chefs
i recently took a class to sharpen ha my
knife skills with elena carp from plated
and apparently i was holding my knife
wrong the whole time and now i'm the
latest victim of big
not chopping your fingers off it's less
than 10 a month with an annual
subscription check out the link in the
description